alors déjà ça sert à rien le fait pas
faut pas le faire non plus tu vas bien
et les gens s'ils attrapent la
prévention devient attrayante pour sa
première journée portes ouvertes
l'institut de promotion de la santé
organise des conférences ateliers et
démonstrations
une manière plus attractive d'attirer le
public selon la directrice
on s'est rendu compte par nos études en
fait que quand on découvrait un lieu une
première fois surtout un lieu de santé
sans avoir une problématique en fait on
y vient beaucoup plus facilement par la
suite c'est pas très facile en fait
d'accéder de parler de santé de manière
générale donc on a voulu mettre en forme
en place différentes formes d'ateliers
donc il y à des mini conférences par
exemple une mini conférence sur l'estimé
de soi
donc à chaque fois ce sont nos
partenaires qui les anime ça permet de
leur donner la visibilité avec ses 23
partenaires lee ps accueille environ
13000 personnes par an aujourd'hui
c'était l'occasion de découvrir la
structure pour les habitants mais aussi
pour les professionnels ce qu'on n'y
pense pas souvent à faire
un partenariat avec mais ça qui est beau
il ya beaucoup de choses de
sensibilisation qu'ils font et c'est
vraiment très intéressant et justement
on est là pour essayer de voir qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire de plus en avait
que en fait dans au sein de notre
hôpital et pour faire de la prévention
au niveau de nos patients le site ouvert
toute l'année accueille la population de
manière totalement anonyme pour une
écoute un bilan de santé ou une
vaccination
un seul objectif pour la structure
promouvoir l'accès à la santé pour tous